demain monsieur giscard d'estaing
prendra le métro ou plutôt il inaugurera
la première ligne du rer le réseau
régional express une réalisation qui est
sans aucun équivalent dans le monde
mais cette manifestation risque d'être
perturbée par des débrayages là aussi à
la demande du seul syndicat cfdt l'air
le rer c'est bien sûr un événement pour
les parisiens un millier d'entre eux
assisteront à son inauguration et puis
de vendredi à dimanche la ratp a bien
fait les choses
toutes les stations du rer seront en
fête avec concerts classiques et de
variétés expositions etc
nous en reparlerons d'une bonne
initiative et puis surtout alors qu'il
fallait une heure et demie pour aller
d'un bout à l'autre de la capitale mais
il faudra dorénavant une demi heure
ça c'est pour paris et ça ne résout pas
tous les problèmes des transports en
commun en france à propos desquels les
organisations et partis de gauche ont
bien des revendications à formuler
mais il faut le reconnaître c'est aussi
ce rer une vitrine à l'exportation le
métro france est très vendues à
l'étranger en avant première michel
chevalet a parcouru cette première ligne
la traversée de paris en un temps record
il est 14 heures 17 nous nous trouvons
dans une rame du rer tout à fait
classique et nous allons en quelque
sorte de vécu une grande première
puisque nous quittons en ce moment la
station de la défense c'est-à-dire
située à l'ouest de paris et nous allons
rallier marne-la-vallée monde est c'est
à dire diamétralement opposées c'est à
dire dans la banlieue est c'est à dire
près de 30 kilomètres que nous allons
parcourir seulement en une demi-heure
c'est là la grande performance du rer
trente secondes plus tard nous passons
sous la seine puis on remonte l'avenue
de la grande armée à cent à l'heure
14h21 étoiles charles de gaulle puis
toujours à cent à l'heure donc tunnel
nous dévalons vers l'opéra la station
auber
maintenant nous empruntons pour la
première fois le tronçon qui traverse
tout paris à 25 mètres sous terre et
14h26 et le centre de paris la station
les à châtelet une véritable cathédrale
avec cette voie parallèle
quatre minutes plus tard nous allons
passer sous l'horloge de la gare de lyon
à nouveau un tunnel parcouru à 80 à
leurs essais nation l'ouest de paris est
enfin relié à l'est on sort de paris à
14h35 pour emprunter la nouvelle ligne
qui va vers la banlieue est marne la
vallée
un viaduc de 1400 mètres de long avec
des écrans antibruit un bond par-dessus
la marne
en escalade les coteaux de bris et bien
il est maintenant 14h48 c'est à dire que
trente et une minutes après notre départ
à la défense et bien nous sommes arrivés
à noisy-le-grand monde a cédé nous avons
effectué une traversée de paris en un
temps record en un temps qui n'a jamais
été réalisée puisque bien sur cette
ligne n'était pas ouvert voilà donc
kokhava sauf le grand miracle de ce
héros vert qui est bête en service donc
à partir d'une offre à la grande
satisfaction des parisiens mais le rrc
plus que la traversée de paris à 25
mètres sous terre il ya cent à l'heure
c'est des travaux gigantesques les plus
grands du xxème siècle 5 milliards de
francs et surtout un nouveau réseau de
transport
c'est le train sous paris les rames de
toutes les banlieues qui entrent sous la
capitale à un bout et ressort à l'autre
voici la première ligne est ouest puis à
châtelet l'arrivée des trains en
provenance du sud qui iront jusqu'au
nord de paris en 1980 tout comme les
trains en provenance de la banlieue sud
est
en somme ce sera sous paris toutes les
minutes
un train à cent à l'heure